[Music]
okay the guy you see next to me is the
most generous billionaire in the world
and I found him
the most generous billionaire ever where
you can get 10 off on your trading fees
these are bad these are very bad but FTX
there are no fees whatsoever and if you
sign up with our link signing up using
my link there are referral links if you
use my link below and the code name Paul
Nash oh stop it please you guys are
embarrassing yourselves listen what a
week it has been for financial
influencers their reputations have just
been going down the toilet people who
promoted absolute garbage companies like
FTX us and block five for millions of
dollars today we're finally seeing the
results as both of those companies are
basically bankrupt and so today I'm
calling out all the influencers who
promoted it some of whom I know and I'm
getting third wave embarrassment from it
you know I know it's mind-bendingly
stupid to imagine that people actually
listen to YouTubers for financial advice
but we all know they do that's why they
get offered these insane Financial deals
and these people had a responsibility to
their fans and they blew it so I want to
talk about it because it's a pretty big
Scandal and it involves a lot of people
I know some of them some of them I've
even done collapse with and just
honestly it's crazy how many of the
biggest Financial channels took deals
promoting this garbage and honestly none
of y'all are getting off the hook today
it's smoke for all of y'all if you do
the crime you get the screen time I
don't care who you are so I kind of
showed a bit of it at the beginning of
this video but um it was incredible to
me as I like looked through the archives
just how many people got bought out by
FTX us and uh let's face facts the
biggest reason for that is money I asked
around the sponsorship deals were absurd
I know a guy much smaller Channel than
me making half a million a year 50k a
month just to promote FTX us so I know
the bigger guys were getting much more
some of them probably the deals were in
the millions so obviously that's a big
reason a lot of them get it but I don't
think that's the only reason because I
think that'd be honestly too easy to say
oh they were just greedy that's why they
they did this I actually think it's
worse than that I talked to a lot of
these guys and they were a fool that's
the scariest part so many of these
experts who are giving you guys advice
totally bought into this Sam character
as this genius billionaire right the
most generous billionaire in the world
who also happened to be paying them
handsomely of course and I just think it
shows how bad the discernment is out
there making videos on how to invest
it's alarming how many people fell for
this guy's ruse and it's alarming how
easy it was to convince them like some
of these guys believed in Sam because he
drives a beat up car Sam doesn't need
the money to buy a Lamborghini or to buy
a Rolex or to impress his friends in
fact his car is a Toyota Corolla it's
you trust the guy more when you see the
car he drives he's worth like 20 billion
dollars and he drives like this kind I
don't want to call it beat up it's like
a it's an older Toyota not he doesn't
even have window tints on them
completely stocked Toyota does that have
to do with anything what does window
tint have to do with Sam's
qualifications as an investor I mean
look it's now coming out guys that at
Alameda research they were just kind of
embarrassingly incompetent and the
evidence was always there but nobody who
is selling FTX bothered to take notice
apparently they were too busy looking at
the window tint here's the CEO of
Alameda for example saying she hardly
uses math at her job yeah absolutely
could pull it off without my math degree
I use very little math
um use a lot of like uh elementary
school math just beyond belief like I
don't want to pretend like I'm some
Nostradamus who saw all this coming and
nobody else did right I did call out FTX
24 hours before it shut down I did call
FTX us out well before like 72 hours
before it shut down but
but I wasn't here with my crystal ball
forecasting all of this years in advance
but that's the reason I didn't promote
this you know I get the same offers as
everyone else but there's no way I'm
gonna risk my audience you guys in a
game of crypto Among Us like will this
guy turn out to be a psycho in a year or
two let's find out uh no no I'm not
gonna do that and it's not because I'm
better than anyone it's just because I
know that even though I know a little
bit about crypto I don't know enough to
know for sure whether these companies
are going to be around and that's the
crazy thing is I think of everyone we're
talking about today I probably know the
most I probably have the biggest claim
to like crypto expert and I would never
feel comfortable saying that because
there's just no way you know and so I
think it exposes a big gaping flaw in
this influencer world where it's not
just the greed it's just this systemic
failure of people to recognize their own
lack of expertise and it's so easy for
charismatic Geniuses to convince these
people based on basically no evidence
take for instance meet Kevin's seal of
approval the guy's brilliant he talks so
very very fast but he's brilliant and I
trust him and I like him yeah really
I talk really fast my Brilliance is
definitely Up For Debate but do you
trust me with all your money because
abysmal and now that this has all come
out some of these guys are now coming
out and apologizing as they should uh
but is it enough because people like
Graham Stefan now has made a video about
it uh basically he said 24 hours before
FTX us went bust like hey baby you
should get your money off ftxus has been
a sponsor here on the channel for the
majority of the Year this one I did not
see coming I think it's pretty safe to
say as a result of that I'm no longer
working with them so if you hold
anything on ftxus you could still take
it out and transfer it to an external
wallet or wherever else you please but
how many people saw this compared to
almost a year of ads or take Tom Nash
someone who's appeared on this channel
you know he took a different approach
and basically said no one signed up
under him the thing that you all deserve
me to talk about FTX I was working with
them a few months ago for about 30 days
somehow during this whole month we were
running the campaign literally nobody
signed up for fdxus they called me and I
was insulted in the beginning and they
said look Tom we gotta cut it short
because we had like a three month plan
to work together
and they said look we're stopping after
one month because nobody's signing up
from your channel yeah I don't know if I
buy that at minimum these are bad
arguments like no one signed up for me
or hey I gave you 24 hours notice like
it's just such an embarrassing standard
for this industry if you can even call
it that because it's just a bunch of
basically random people giving their
opinion about finance and truthfully I
just think it's a big lesson another
lesson the millionth lesson that you
shouldn't be actually taking real advice
from the people who who you watch on
these screens they're entertainers and
they don't know much more than you about
what they're actually selling
um now I will say one small thing in
their defense a lot of smart people did
get fooled BlackRock was an investor and
for you Millennials even Kevin O'Leary
got caught with his pants down number
one I'm an investor in FTX International
Equity number two I'm an investor in FTX
U.S Equity number three I have accounts
with FTX I have Capital there inside of
my account obviously like everybody else
I'm gated currently yikes I guess it
just shows how bad the advice out there
was and how many people so many of these
Financial experts were full and then
made fools of themselves by promoting
this junk now the next thing I want to
talk about is a company called blockfi
which paused withdrawals yesterday it
looks like they're also going to be
bankrupt
um and I just want to talk about the
influencers who promoted them as well
here's a few clips of what I'm talking
about
[Music]
I have never taken on a paid sponsorship
on my Channel please use my link to sign
up to this credit card and even though
I'm not contractually obligated to speak
positively about them don't forget to
grab up to 250 worth of free Bitcoin
using this block by link right here it
would really help me out a lot we didn't
touch on this at all but the thing I'm
most excited about for this year is uh
the Bitcoin rewards credit card which
we're launching in the second oh now
this is just a lot more of the same junk
and once again I mean I would say this
even more so we have evidence that these
people were just bad at predicting this
stuff they just had no idea what was
going on because Andre dick for instance
said he keeps all his money on blockfi
which just went under I keep most of my
money in fact all of my crypto with
blockfy both my ethereum my Bitcoin
everything rip to your portfolio my man
now I also want to say meet Kevin I
think personally invested 420
000 into this platform which cool number
I guess uh so I think he also lost a ton
of money on that but I just think it's
just a big lesson that you cannot take
advice from these people I know the
parasocial relationship is there and you
start to feel that maybe they know
something but a lot of them are Googling
it like five minutes before they go live
okay that's the truth of it um and I
just think a lot of these influencers
themselves should take a hard look at
themselves because as much as it's
ridiculous that anyone takes their
advice they actually do and it's gonna
hurt a lot of people for a long time so
that's basically it I I just wanted to
talk about this because I think it's so
important and it involves a lot of the
people in a I think a lot of my viewers
might watch some of these people so yeah
I just wanted to make a quick video on
that